okay we got a question for greg here
the question is from michael uh the
question
is how important
is delayed onset muscle soreness i've
been powerlifting for a little over
18 months and so far i haven't had any
significant amount of soreness
my program has reasonably high volume
and intensity
um so basically the question is is that
problematic that he hasn't run into any
delayed onset muscle soreness
would you mind reading the end of that
question
just so a we can get it on the record
but b it's your words not mine
so okay here we go michael
um he said kind regards from germany ps
the netherlands must be destroyed i just
want to jump out it's like when you're
a a politician and someone at your rally
gets a little bit carried away and you
gotta grab the mic and say hey now
let's let's not go overboard the
netherlands should not be destroyed
um they should be beaten into submission
and turned into a vassal state
no no greg just relax
you should we should encourage people to
say snarky things
about the netherlands and i i think that
is a sufficient punishment for what
they've done
we can we can agree to disagree okay
would you would you care to talk about
delayed onset muscle soreness
sure um so yeah i think
so let me start by saying delayed onset
muscle soreness
is probably to some degree a proxy
for whether or not training was hard
enough to be effective
but is also a really bad proxy
so essentially i think like
if you're training and you're making
progress you're getting bigger
you're getting stronger i don't care if
you're getting sore or not
if so this kind of cuts both ways so
some people are like
oh man i'm still getting super sore from
my workouts
like is that a bad thing if you're
making progress
like if you're you're objectively
gaining muscle and getting stronger
it's not a bad thing that you're still
getting sore and vice versa
if you're building muscle getting
stronger and you're not sore it's not a
bad thing that you're not getting sore
so like getting some degree of sore from
training is probably
to some degree correlated with the
effectiveness of your training but
it would be a very very weak correlation
so
i think more like if
if you're training you're not getting
sore and you're also not making progress
i think that lack of soreness may be
a somewhat decent indication that maybe
you should be training a little bit
harder
um but i think like
other just like subjective assessments
of
you know i feel good all the time i'm
sleeping well
i'm showing no no overt signs of
overreaching or overtraining
and i'm not making progress and i'm not
getting sore
kind of putting that whole picture
together probably gives you
like the overall takeaway that hey i'm
probably not training hard enough to be
making progress
maybe volume needs to go up maybe i need
to push a little bit closer to failure
maybe maybe i need to
choose more challenging exercises with a
longer range of motion which
like longer ranges of motion are
generally associated with a little bit
more soreness
so like you know if if you have that
whole picture
not making progress feeling fresh all
the time and not sore
then yeah maybe that's indicative of
something is going bad
insofar as you're not training hard
enough but if
everything in the gym is going good and
you're making gains
the the fact that you're not sore is
great like
i don't think people want to necessarily
walk around
being crazy sore all the time for its
own sake
so i mean i i and i've seen it
i've seen very different responses from
different people so
like some folks legitimately like
you know get a couple weeks of training
under their belt they build up some like
repeated bout effect
type adaptations to protect them from
muscle damage
and then they make great progress and
they're just never sore from training
and that's cool and then other people
they do
you know they're not as sore three
months into training as they were three
days into training
but they do still get pretty sore after
most of their workouts
but they still make good progress and
that's also cool so so i i do think that
there's probably some
like innate characteristic that
determines whether you maintain
a significant level of ongoing soreness
uh as you continue training and i do
think that does differ quite a bit
between people but
i mean ultimately the question is are
you making progress or not
not are you getting sore or not